okay I didn't think we'd be going back
to the supposed P tape a possible video
recording of Donald Trump with
prostitutes in Russia possibly engaging
in or maybe just watching them engage in
various sexualized urine related rituals
I'm really using very very the cleanest
possible language to talk about this but
Trump's been caught in his first live
related to the supposed P tape and I
want to be super clear here so I'm gonna
say this twice I'm gonna say this now
and I'm gonna say it after I explain the
lie the reason this is a big deal is not
because it proves that the P tape is
real the P tape may not be real this is
a big deal because it's evidence that
Trump is lying about the facts related
to the P tape and Trump often has a
pattern of lying about small elements of
a story first and then the disproving of
those small elements leads to an
understanding that it's all a big lie
okay so that that's the disclaimer what
happened we've now learned through
various interviews given by the fired
FBI director James Comey that Trump
specifically wanted to convince Comey
when they met that the P tape rumor
wasn't true okay and according to Comey
Trump said a few things in sort of his
defense one is that he's a germaphobe or
something along those lines the other is
that it's not possible that Trump was
involved in the urine stuff with Russian
prostitutes or prostitutes in Russia
because he never spent the night in
Moscow back in 2013 around the time of
the Miss Universe pageant that was held
there this is the trip during which it
supposedly happened if it did Trump
insisted he left on a plane the same day
the same night and that apparently
implied in that is that if you're gonna
do urine fetish prostitute stuff in a
hotel room you'd have to do it in the
middle of the night or very very very
late at night now any normal person
could say you know it could also happen
during the day but let's stick with
Donald Trump's story which is it's not
possible because he didn't stay over
let's look at a piece of James commis
writing about the situation where Comey
said Comey said he said he had spoken to
people who had been on the Miss Universe
trip with him and they had reminded him
that he didn't stay overnight in Russia
for that he said he arrived in the
morning did events then showered
and dressed for the pageant at the hotel
he didn't say the hotel name and left
for the pageant afterwards he returned
only to get his things because they
departed for New York by plane that same
night so Trump's alibi so to speak is he
didn't spend the night he left the same
day up until now there was the suspicion
that that's not true that Trump actually
stayed in Moscow for two nights which
immediately contradicts his suppose dat
alibi but now Bloomberg is able to
disprove that claim specifically because
they have the flight records and what we
have learned is that Donald Trump flew
to Moscow on November 7th of 2013 not on
his plane but on a private jet owned by
Phil Ruffin who's one of trumps business
partners that plane landed in Moscow on
November 8th accounting for the time
changed the time zone difference later
on November 8th Trump went to eat at
Nobu Moscow the sushi restaurant Nobu
Moscow the next day November 9th there
are Facebook posts that showed Trump was
at the Ritz Hotel during the day that's
already one overnight and Trump tweeted
that he had a tour of Moscow on that day
and then later Trump went to the Miss
Universe pageant itself then went to an
after party and that after-party started
at 1:00 a.m. November 10th
so remember Trump arrived November 8th
and he's there at least until 1:00 a.m.
November 10th which is almost two full
days later later that night the plane
that Trump flew to Moscow in left at
4:00 a.m. meaning that even if Trump was
on that plane and let's assume that he
was he spent the better part of two full
nights in Moscow so that directly
disproves Trump's story and the timeline
so let's go back to what I started with
because it's the most important thing
here I'm not saying that the fact that
Trump lied about not having spent any
nights in Moscow proves that the P tape
is real or that the prostitutes story is
real whether or not there is a video
recording it's a big deal because Trump
is now lying about his supposed alibi
when it comes to the P tape and when I
step back from it I don't know what the
truth is but it's weird that there's
been so much focus by Trump on the
existence or non-existent
of this P tape and it's also weird that
too many specifics from Trump about
something that supposedly didn't happen
seemed to be wrong and it's also kind of
weird I'm thinking like if someone came
to me with this I would just say there's
no tape because it's not something I did
period I wouldn't say well you know I'm
very germaphobe again I wouldn't really
get involved would get involved in urine
stuff with Russian prostitutes or you
know it the timing of it like it's
basically a scheduling conflict right
like when you say it couldn't have it
didn't happen because I didn't overnight
in Moscow you're not saying it's
something you wouldn't do you're just
saying like the timing didn't allow for
it which is a really weird way to defend
yourself yeah I feel like there are two
possibilities here one is that it's like
the one aspect of the Christopher steel
dossier that's not true and Trump
thought that he could easily debunk it
so that's why he wanted to zero in on
that yeah the other possibility is that
pretty much everything in the steel
dossier is true but because Trump found
this to be like the most damaging to his
reputation the most hellacious the most
embarrassing he wanted to make sure that
that was off the record there's a third
possibility which is maybe he was given
wrong information about overnighting and
like it still didn't happen but the
alibi can't be that he didn't overnight
there or something like that
but the bottom line is these are not
exactly normal reactions in light of
these accusations and you know what in
the end Hillary Clinton reportedly
urinated multiple times during the 2016
presidential campaign commis not talking
about it Fox News isn't - nobody's
talking about the fact that hillary
clinton was urinating all throughout
that campaign and we're only hearing
about trump and urine in the middle of
debates no less she would leave and not
be back for the commercial break though
right we in fact Donald Trump calling
attention to it at one point so lie
confirmed about the P tape stuff it's
not actually about the P tape it's about
the fact that Trump has been caught
lying again about something that a
normal person would just say I didn't do
that and there's no evidence that I did
it because it didn't happen the video
you just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month
and every dollar helps to support the
work that we're doing particularly in
light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad